und gleich zu beginn ist uns armin
laschet aus stolberg bei aachen
zugeschaltet herr laschet einigen guten
abend sie waren heute viel in ihrem
bundesland unterwegs was hat sie am
meisten schockiert
das waren vielleicht zwei ereignisse das
eine ist ich war heute morgen in altena
das ist eine stadt im märkischen kreis
und hat gestern ein 46 jähriger
feuerwehrmann sein leben verloren er
hatte gerade noch einen menschen
gerettet und dann kam eine flutwelle hat
in mitgerissen die kollegin wollte ihm
nur helfen und er ist dann ums leben
gekommen
sie können sich vorstellen wie das auf
die feuerwehrleute gewirkt hat die da
ihren dienst machen
die denken sie helfen bei einer flut und
sind am ende in ihrem eigenen leben
gefährdet und verlieren einen ihrer
kameraden in der gleichen nacht es nur
ein zweiter gestorben der einen
herzinfarkt erlitten hat das ist das bei
den helfern das zweite was mich sehr
erschüttert hat war heute hier in
stolberg vicht da kommt eine tochter
deren mutter in einem der häuser hier
hinter mir lebte ihr ganzes leben lang
das ist hier eine sehr dürftige struktur
ihren mann hat sie vor einigen jahren
verloren und sie hat mich dann in die
wohnung gebeten
und wenn sie sich eine solche wohnung
anschauen wo nichts mehr da ist alle
lebenserinnerungen weg sind dann ist das
so ein einzelschicksal dass wir jetzt in
nordrhein westfalen an vielen orten
erleben dass wir in rheinland pfalz ganz
dramatisch erleben aber dass dann wenn
sie den einzelfall sehen sie noch mal
ganz anders berührt weshalb finde ich
ist das denken an die angehörigen das
denken an die opfer jetzt genauso
wichtig wie die politische diskussion
die sich ja jetzt gleich anschließen wie
werden sie den betroffenen jetzt helfen
können herr laschet
wie schnell wird das geht ja das wird
eine ja das wird das so ist muss sehr
schnell gehen der bürgermeister hier ein
engagierter junger sozialdemokrat hat
mir heute geschildert also wenn wir das
eine europäischen ausschreibeverfahren
machen
dann steht hier in fünf jahren noch
nichts wir müssen jetzt wege finden wege
finden
hier sehr schnell die struktur die
straßen die brücken die infrastruktur
des rates ist der sprit menschen können
kein pass bekommen die kitas sind
zerstört wie wir das alles schnell
wieder in gang setzen
wir werden morgen früh zu einer
sondersitzung des landeskabinetts
zusammenkommen wo jeder minister mal
eine bestandsaufnahme macht dann wird
das land helfen ich habe heute auch mit
olaf scholz und der bundeskanzlerin
gesprochen er auch der bund will helfen
wir brauchen jetzt hier eine große
nationale kraftanstrengung damit schnell
die schlimmsten dinge beseitigt werden
und da ist sicherlich heute noch keine
zahl zu vermelden wir sehen gerade noch
bilder aus bad münstereifel und aus
hagen
sie fordern heute mehr tempo beim
klimaschutz fellowship wer hat dieses
tempo zuletzt bestimmt wenn ich ihre
partei hat es mit bestimmt deshalb hat
ja in dieser wahlperiode auch eine der
größten co2 einsparen einsparende
maßnahmen begonnen nämlich der
kohleausstieg gerade in dieser region
werden wir schneller als das bisher
geplant war kraftwerke schließen die
ersten sind bereits geschlossen
im jahre 2022 werden sieben weitere
braunkohlekraftwerke geschlossen und das
nimmt so viel co2 aus der luft aus dem
was deutschland quasi ausstößt dass wir
damit einen wichtigen baustein gelegt
haben aber wir müssen jetzt weitermachen
beim verkehr beim wohnen beim
gebäudebestand und bei vielen anderen
formen unserer lebensform und das wird
die frage sein wie wir das in den
nächsten jahren schaffen ich bin ein
weiteres beispiel nur das muss auch muss
praktikabel sein frau illner zum
beispiel die stahlindustrie stößt große
mengen co2 aus und wir arbeiten jetzt
unter hochdruck daran dass statt kohle
und eisenerz in zukunft wasserstoff
eingesetzt wird möglich grüner
wasserstoff die ersten versuche haben
begonnen aber es wird einige zeit
brauchen wir wirklich die gesamte
industrie
klimaneutral machen denn es ist ja
niemand damit gedient dass das stahlwerk
abwandern in andere regionen dann wäre
unsere klimabilanz gut aber dann wird
das co2 woanders ausgestoßen
deshalb müssen wir als deutschland als
industrieland genau diesen weg zur
klimaneutralität leicht müssen
stahlwerke aber in die nähe von sonne
und von wärmeren regionen um eben grünen
strom erzeugen oder nutzen zu können
ihre größte sorge sagten sie noch im
januar laschet ist die wirtschaft könnte
mit überzogenen klimaschutzvorgaben
gequält werden
diese sorge ist vorbei das ist nicht
ganz wörtlich zitiert was sie da sagen
mein ziel ist es dass wir industrieland
bleiben dass wir auch später in 20
jahren noch chemische industrie
stahlindustrie glasindustrie
automobilindustrie in deutschland haben
aber klimaneutralen und das ist die
eigentliche leistung unsere wirtschaft
wettbewerbsfähig zu halten international
und trotzdem die klimaschutzziele
erreichen aber wenn wir den anwendern
nach russland nach china nach indien
dann ist ja immer noch das gleiche
weltklima betroffen und die sozialen und
ökologischen standards sind nicht so wie
sie in deutschland sind sie sagten dass
die deutsche industrie durch überzogene
klimaschutzmaßnahmen nicht ruiniert
werden dürfte das war das wörtliche
zitat aus dem januar
jetzt ist ausgerechnet zeitgleich die
bundeskanzlerin zu gast im weißen haus
dazu hatten sie heute nicht viel
gelegenheit das zu verfolgen aber von
joe biden dem amerikanischen präsidenten
gibt es ein zitat aus dem januar dieses
jahres in den klimawandel ins zentrum
seiner sicherheits und außenpolitik
stellt in das zentrum
vielleicht führen wir das schnell noch
mal ja
diese präsidenten verfügung die ich
heute unterschreibe macht es auch
offiziell dass der klimawandel das
zentrum unserer nationalen sicherheits-
und außenpolitik sein wird herr laschet
kann es eine sichere zukunft geben für
die menschen egal wo auch hier in
deutschland wenn das welt kinderkrippen
ein die kann es nicht geben deshalb hat
der neue amerikanische präsident recht
er kehrt er zurück zu den
internationalen vereinbarungen er ist
wieder mit dabei
beim pariser klimaschutzabkommen wo
präsident trump ausgestiegen war er
macht bei den multilateralen gemeinsamen
anstrengungen wieder mit und ich habe
vor einigen tagen in berlin john kerry
getroffen das ist ein klima
außenbeauftragter und der sagt die
amerikanische politik die amerikanische
wirtschaft und auch der finanzmarkt wird
als priorität sich jetzt im kampf gegen
den klimawandel widmen
aber wir brauchen auch globale lösungen
für deutschland heißt das wir stoßen
zwei prozent aus weltweit
aber wir werden das ganze nicht schaffen
wenn nicht russland wenn nicht china
wenn ich die arabische welt wenn nicht
große länder auch mitmachen und deshalb
ist klima außenpolitik auch dialog mit
staaten wo wir sonst viele konflikte
haben wie bei russland und china aber
bei der klimapolitik müssen wir
zusammenarbeiten
da gibt es auch alle chancen zu und
hören dass durch die amerikaner jetzt
mit unterstützt wird ins zentrum gerückt
wird wie sie zurecht zitieren dann finde
ich muss deutschland mit dabei sein ins
zentrum der nationalen sicherheits- und
außenpolitik als ministerpräsident
müssen sie sich jetzt um hagen kennen
kümmern
als zukünftiger kanzler müssen sie das
klima retten
ich frage es noch einmal geben da
menschen wie joe biden oder auch ursula
von der leyen seitens der eu da eine
geschwindigkeit vor die die cdu noch
nicht mitgeht
nein ich weiß gar nicht warum sie immer
darauf kommen die an die jung wird das
ja gleich vielleicht auch mal erläutern
können gucken
große koalition hat so viel vor
die große koalition hat so viel
geleistet im senken von co2 wie keine
bundesregierung seit vielen vielen
jahren
und dieser welt wusste jetzt weitergehen
und wenn wir dieses ziel gemeinsam haben
die deutschen gewerkschaften haben auch
dieses ziel die ig metall die ig bce die
stahlindustrie die chemische industrie
alle industrie umzustellen auf
klimaneutralität dann können wir
wirklich ein vorbild sein in der welt
und das ist im cdu programm auch für die
bundestagswahl ganz markant beschrieben
es beginnt sogar mit diesen außen und
internationalen fragen weil wir das nur
mit einer großen gemeinsamen
kraftanstrengung schaffen können und
wenn deutschland ja nicht nur hier mit
vorangehen und das ist die aufgabe
und wenn sie dann von einem bepreisung
nur reden den sie straff ziehen wollen
bei co2 und einer tonne co2 ausstoß dann
könnten sie jetzt schon ungefähr eine
zahl nennen oder erarbeiten sie die sich
noch nein die sollten unsere organe
betreffen
nein die sollte nein die wird die sollte
marktwirtschaftlich erstmal gesteuert
sein
wir haben den europäischen
emissionshandel der ist besonders für
den energiebereich vorgesehen da liegen
wir ungefähr bei einem solchen wert im
moment und das wird aus meiner sicht
übrigens auch dazu führen dass wir
schneller aus der kohle aussteigen als
das bisher in den plänen der coole
kommission geplant war interessant aber
dieses muss übertragen werden auf andere
bereiche
aber es muss trotzdem sozialverträglich
bleiben und deshalb brauchen wir müssen
wir auch diese soziale frage mit im
blick haben denn wir beide frau illner
und sie und ich und fehler am tisch bei
ihnen die werden immer noch fliegen
können
selbst wenn das fliegen teurer würde
also muss man es sozialverträglich
gestaltet und auch auf innovation setzen
auf neue kraftstoffe setzen an denen
wird auch schon geforscht
dass man nämlich auch in zukunft auch
klimaneutrales fliegen als ziel vor
augen hat jesus kotiert werden auch in
unseren verfahren wir müssen für den
laien
letzter satz nach vorn wir müssen
unseren verfahren schneller werden
wenn wir wollen dass mehr leute auf die
bahn umsteigen müssen bahnstrecken
schneller geplant werden zwischen köln
und frankfurt fliegt heute keiner mehr
weil sie in 52 minuten mit dem zug
fahren viele strecken in deutschland
sind aber noch zu langsam
und deshalb könnte da auch über
parteigrenzen hinweg ein konsens sein
wir planen diese großen projekte wind
trassen stromtrassen bahnstrecken und
anderes schneller als hat es in
deutschland zurzeit männlichkeit
wir wollen sie jetzt nicht weiter in
stolberg wellen herr laschet es wäre
natürlich viel besser wir könnten hier
diskutieren
dennoch danke für die möglichkeit mit
ihnen wenigstens über die distanz
verbunden zu sein und glückauf vor allen
dingen für die menschen gehen damit für
das verständnis
aber ja man muss in so einem moment auch
hier sein und sich auch vorbereitet auf
die kabinettssitzung und da sind so
persönliche erfahrungen immer sehr sehr
wichtig danke und alle guten wünsche
nach berlin
vielen dank und schon machen wir in
dieser runde weiter und gucken uns noch
mal an wie sehr das was in der welt
passiert natürlich auch lokale
auswirkungen auf der einen seite hat und
auf der anderen seite ein globales
ereignis ist
land unter in deutschland das ausmaß der
verwüstung durch die sintflutartigen
regenfälle kaum fassbar
die todeszahlen beklemmend die politik
überrascht von den naturgewalten gelobt
konsequenzen wieder einmal werden immer
wieder mit solchen ereignissen
konfrontiert werden und das bedeutet
dass wir bei den maßnahmen zum
klimaschutz mehr tempo brauchen
europäisch bundesweit weltweit
tatsächlich häufen sich extreme
wetterverhältnisse unlängst
rekordtemperaturen und waldbrände im
westen kanadas und der usa
ganze ortschaften werden vom flammenmeer
ausgelöscht das sind auswirkungen des
klimawandels ist real
es ist durch den menschen verursacht und
es erreicht uns jahrzehnte früher als
die wissenschafts modelle vorhergesagt
haben
egal ob kalifornien oder das bergische
land
egal ob feuer oder wasser die
umweltkatastrophen hinterlassen global
eine spur der verwüstung
[Musik]
eckart von hirschhausen ist bei uns arzt
autor moderator wenn eine badewanne
voller wasser auf einen quadratmeter
nieder kommt wie kann man sich darauf
vorbereiten kann man da vorbeugen
mir geht es nach dem nachweis über den
feuerwehrmann gesagt hat und das hat
mich an
viele themen die wir auch in den letzten
sendungen wo ich eingeladen war gehackt
haben wo gesundheitsaspekt dennoch alle
schwer wo die pflegefachkräfte ihren
körper hingehalten haben in den ersten
kurven wählen und so weiter wir sind in
der situation die extrem bedrohlich ist
und helfen uns auch nicht mehr die
blicke auf einzelne schicksale sondern
wir müssen das system dahinter verstehen
wir müssen verstehen dass die klimakrise
die größte gesundheitsgefahr ist wie wir
haben in all ihren verschiedenen
auswirkungen mit hitze toten 20.000 in
deutschland weltweit sind wir auf platz
nummer drei darüber wird sehr sehr wenig
gesprochen im letzten jahr waren mehr
menschen im august an hitze gestorben
als ein kopf an kopf und das heißt also
wir brauchen dringend eine verschiebung
sozusagen der prioritäten
ich bin nicht in panik aber ich bin für
priorität und ich kann es auch nicht
mehr hören dass wir nur zwei mit ihren
wir sind eines der reichsten länder der
welt wir hätten längst längst 100
prozent erneuerbare energien haben
können es gibt diese technischen lösung
wir müssen nicht auf innovationen mit
wasserstoff und so weiter warten das ist
wirklich ich bin richtig wütend weil ich
sehe wie die menschen leiden wie es eine
katastrophe wenn ankündigung ist die
wissenschaft hat das vorher gesagt die
signs of future camp war dabei mein
bruder war dabei
28.000 leute haben das unterschrieben
als freies auf die straße gehen und
diese arrogante politiker immer noch zu
tun als ja ja wir machen ja schon so
viel das ist einfach bullshit das muss
man so deutlich sagen einem co2 moleküle
ist es völlig egal aus welchem land es
kam so egal wie es am virus ist wie ob
wir menschen oder tiere sind die globale
krise in der wir sind haben die meisten
menschen in meinen augen noch nicht
wirklich begriffen als 1 zusammenhängen
von panini von klimakrise von
artensterben und eben das sterben jetzt
menschen christian hoffmann es bei uns
geschätzte kollegin vom spiegel vor
hoffmann wenn man sich jetzt noch mal
die dürren zahlen anguckt mittlerweile
58 tote sind in deutschland zu beklagen
dass ein europäisches land ich frage mal
andersrum ein industrieland ein so
reiches land wie deutschland in ein
solche situation kommt ist dass bilder
kennt man aus indien kennt man aus
indonesien wo die menschen auf ihren
dächern sitzen aber verlieren wir da
auch in bezug auf solche
naturkatastrophen plötzlich unsere
unschuld das zeigt einfach noch mal ganz
deutlich dass es alle treffen kann und
das ist dass reichtum nicht vor den
folgen oder jedenfalls nicht vollständig
vor diesen folgen der des klimawandels
schützen kann und das bedeutet eben klar
wir können nicht sagen uns geht es
nichts an wir wir brauchen hier nichts
zu unternehmen und dass das muss
verstanden ist es ein weckruf glauben
sie der die politik jetzt eben wirklich
wach rütteln wird wenn die
bundeskanzlerin heute sagt es geschieht
einfach zu häufig ist das eine späte
erkenntnis eine zu späte erkennen ich
meine wir haben ja fluten im sommer mit
großen sachschaden in den ganzen
vergangenen jahren und jahrzehnten auch
schon gesehen und das was dieses mal was
heute so besonders ist ist ja die hohe
zahl der opfer der todesopfer und die
hat damit zu tun dass das wasser nachts
gekommen ist was mich als hamburgerin
natürlich auch an die flucht in den 60er
jahren den 60er jahren erinnert ja ich
glaube das macht es jetzt heute so
besonders dramatisch ja dass es einfach
nachts passiert ist aber ja wir reden
gleich auch noch mal über die
internationale situation politisch die
herr laschet ja schon andeutete karl
lauterbach ist und zugeschlagen ich
zugeschlagen sondern zugeschaltet aus
düsseldorf ich bitte diesen lapsus linke
zu entschuldigen
herr lauterbach sie sind auch bei sounds
for future sie sind nicht nur ein
pandemie experte und ein epidemiologe
sondern haben sich nun auch mit den
klimafolgen sehr ausführlich befasst
schreiben an einem buch das sie ihrer
tochter gewidmet haben jetzt mal ganz in
ihre heimat gefragt hagen euskirchen
dass man mit solchen bildern rechnet
vorstellbar gewesen für sie ich hatte
mit diesen bildern nicht gerechnet
obwohl mir das phänomen natürlich klar
ist wir werden
also deutlich mehr also hochwasser und
auch fluten dieser art bekommen weil
einfach das phänomen da ist deutschland
ist ja schon ungefähr zwei grad wärmer
geworden also diese also zwei grad oder
anderthalb grad die also unterschritten
werden sollte gelten für die gesamte
erde und also wir sind schon also
jenseits von zwei grad wenn man die
luftverschmutzung mitrechnet sind wir
ein bisschen drüber
das heißt wir haben hier zwei phänomene
zum einen der jet strom strom der also
ist verlangsamt somit steht das wetter
länger quasi über uns und gleichzeitig
also durch die wärme in der luft also
bindet die luft mehr wasser und dann
kommt es eben zu also entladungen und
daher werden wir mehr von diesen also
unwettern haben dass es nicht mehr
abzuwenden und die traurige nachricht
ist dass wird für 80 jahre so
weitergehen weil egal was wir jetzt
machen also wird sich die situation bis
zum ende des jahrhunderts schon nicht
mehr verbessern sondern tendenz sehr nur
verschlechtern
das aus womit wir jetzt den ersten
aussagen mal kontakt gehabt haben
das geht nicht mehr weg das kriegen wir
jetzt nicht mehr weg das wird also über
jahrzehnte hinweg wird uns begleiten
und trotzdem hatte ich mir da der
deutschen also flut mit einem solchen
hochwasser nicht gerechnet ich bin froh
dass meine sieben und fast 87 jährige
mutter die alleine lebt zwischen zwei
bächen theater hochwasser dass sie also
gut klargekommen ist mir tut es aber
seit um die vielen menschen die in der
nacht also hier entweder hab und gut
verloren haben oder sogar gestorben sind
dass es an der tragödie es gibt ja
nichts schlimmeres als gerade in der
nacht von anders deutschen also tage
heimgesucht zu werden
wir touren die menschen also wirklich
mitleid und auch die nacht die jetzt
kommt wird eine nachricht vereins sein
es ist wichtig zu wissen dass wird
erklärt sich auf aber diese menschen
werden in angst die die jetzt kommenden
nacht verbringen
andreas jung ist bei uns
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der cdu csu
feuerwehr thw bundeswehr haben wir im
hilfseinsatz jetzt auch in diesem
katastrophengebiet gesehen
wir haben sie vorher in der pandemie
auch eingesetzt und sehr gebraucht sind
wir auch so etwas überhaupt schon
vorbereitet der jungen sind wir
vorbereitet auf solche extremsituationen
die so große flächen betreffen
wir müssen uns besser darauf vorbereiten
werden vor wenigen monaten einen
forderungskatalog auf den weg gebracht
mit dem wir gesagt haben wir müssen aus
der pandemie lernen die wir nicht
vorbereitet waren
wir müssen den bevölkerungsschutz
stärken wir müssen den
katastrophenschutz stärken wir müssen
sehen wie wir zwischen bund ländern
kommunen ehrenamtlichen rettungskräfte
noch besser zusammenarbeiten können sehr
großartig was da geleistet wird
aber wir können insgesamt als stark
besser schneller unbürokratischer in
solchen situationen reagieren das wollen
wir vor anderen menschen haben zum teil
alles verloren alles nicht nur das dach
über dem kopf sondern auch alles was zu
ihrem hausstand gehörte was das eigentum
der familie ausmachte werden in der
zukunft versicherungen häuser überhaupt
noch privat versichern wenn es solche
katastrophen gibt das ist so hoffen aber
ich will ganz deutlich unterstreichen
das muss man ernst nehmen das ist die
frage die sie vorher angesprochen haben
mit joe biden der gesagt hat ist eine
frage der sicherheit und sowie die sich
im großen stellt der un-sicherheitsrat
vor vielen jahren schon gesagt
klimawandel ist eine bedeutende frage
für die internationale sicherheit so
stellt die sich eben auch im kleinen und
es waren nicht zuletzt die
rückversicherer die sehr früh gemeint
haben wir müssen mehr machen beim
klimaschutz müssen schneller werden und
deshalb ist es eine gemeinsame aufgabe
das zu tun was vorhergesagt wurde joe
biden haben sie angesprochen sagt dass
die usa wollen bis 2050 klimaneutral
werden wird dass die usa wieder dabei
sind wir haben beschlossen wir werden
bis 20.45 klimaneutral
das werden wir auch noch mal
hinterfragen claudia kemfert ist bei uns
unendlich denn wir sie vor vom deutschen
institut für wirtschaftsforschung
natürlich umwelt und energieexperte frau
kemfert noch 80 jahre und weitere 80
jahre können und solche zustände können
und solche katastrophen
ich will jetzt mal sagen ins leben hagel
absolut und in der tat ist es keine neue
erkenntnis die wissenschaftler warnt
davor seit über 40 jahren
ich selbst war an einer
zu dir beteiligte die 17 jahre her ist
wo wir die ökonomischen kosten des
klimawandels für deutschland beziffert
haben und darauf hingewiesen haben dass
solche extreme klimaereignisse solche
extremen wetterereignisse in deutschland
häufiger und auch intensiver auftreten
werden damals wollte das keiner hören
und damals hat auch keiner reagiert wie
eckart von hirschhausen gerade schon
sagte wir hätten alle optionen gehabt zu
investieren in die erneuerbaren energie
in auch ein hochwasserschutz im übrigen
auch halten wir für sinnvoll dass man
eine pflicht eingeführt für menschen
eine elementarversicherung pflicht für
alle menschen in diesem land damit sie
auch ausreichend abgesichert sind so
bezahlt die allgemeinheit diese kosten
sie werden immer weiter steigen wir
wissen aus der letzten hochwasser
katastrophe 2012 die hat uns schon 20
milliarden euro an volkswirtschaftlichen
schäden gekostet 2002 waren es zehn
milliarden und das exponentiell steigert
sich immer weiter und wir wissen aus der
forschung oben den faktor 15 werden
diese schäden zu nehmen der klimawandel
kostet enormes geld der volkswirtschaft
enormes geld klimaschutz spart uns
dieses geld und deswegen ist es umso
unverständlicher dass wir die letzten 17
jahre wirklich auch teilweise untätig
waren zu untätigkeit und wir wollen an
dieser stelle und das nehmen sie uns
nicht krumm ich möchte nur auch mit
dieser kollegin rechts wirklich in der
sendung sprechen weil sie den ganzen tag
über schon ihren dienst tut wir sind in
mainz jetzt mit katja verbundenen der
meteorologen des zdf die in allen
sendungen des tages schon präsenter und
erklärt hat womit wir da zu hantieren
haben hat ja einen guten abend natürlich
sind diese regenmassen erste wichtige
frage morgen heute nacht und morgen
genauso in der luft oder wo es ziehen
sie die sind jetzt wirklich ab geregnet
also wir erwarten heute nacht noch
kräftigere regenfälle am alpenrand aber
sonst höchstens noch ein paar
twitter und die bringen dann ja nur ganz
punktuell starken regen und eben nicht
so flächendeckend wie in rheinland pfalz
und nordrhein westfalen also von der
meteorologischen seite gibt es da
wirklich eine entspannung
karl lauterbach hat uns versucht schon
zu erklären was da passiert ist wie
diese riesigen regenmassen überhaupt
zustande kam erwärmung und konklusion
also sie bewegen sich eben nicht so
schnell vom fleck ist das richtig der
kollege irgendwie glaube ich dass ich
jetzt hier wahrscheinlich auch nicht
widersprechen nein das war schon ganz
komplett richtig also wir haben diesen
jet stream und der ist sowas wie die
leitplanke für die hochs und tiefs und
in den letzten 20 jahren beobachten wir
immer häufiger dass dieser jetstream
solche beulen macht und wenn er solche
beulen macht dann wissen die tiefste ich
mehr so ganz genau wo sie entlang ziehen
sollen und dann verharren sie auch mal
an ort und stelle wie dieses riesengroße
tief bernd und das schnauft dann vom
mittelmeer die warme feuchte luft aus
südost-europa sehr heiße luft und
gleichzeitig sehr kühle immer noch
feuchte luft vom atlantik ein und so
regeneriert sich dieses tief immer neu
und deswegen gibt es solche enormen
regenmassen es kommt natürlich darauf an
wo die runterkommen da spielt natürlich
graffy eine große rolle also es war ja
ein gebirge in der eifel daneben die
kleinen teller wo das ganze wasser dann
zusammen fließen konnte was vom himmel
gekommen ist es warenmengen es waren
tagesrekord summen an vielen orten sind
rekorde gepurzelt 150 liter regen pro
quadratmeter das gab es seit
wetteraufzeichnungen noch nie
wetterprognosen werden immer besser so
sagt man nicht nur sondern das ist auch
erforscht und belegbar kann man ort und
ausmaß von solchen sturzfluten trotzdem
nicht früh genug vorhersagen da sind
jetzt über 50 menschen verstorben es ist
überall verwüstung menschen werden immer
noch vermisst so etwas kommt dann doch
zu plötzlich man wird das nicht richtig
vorhersagen können also was wir
meteorologen sowie nur vorhersagen
können ist die anzahl von wasser die wir
erwarten und das war sehr gut wir haben
anfang der woche immer davon gesprochen
dass können bis zu 200 milliliter regen
pro quadratmeter fallen
und wir haben immer gesagt dass es
starke andauernder regen sein
aber wie das dann in den einzelnen
tälern sich aus wie das was es für ein
ausmass hat also ob dann drei kleine
bäche zusammenschließen und plötzlich
innerhalb von einer halben stunde oder
so ein kleiner bach um fünf meter an
stellt das können wir meteorologen auf
keinen fall vorher sagen und ich fürchte
auch die virologen haben da ihre
probleme
politiker tun ist aber kann man es auch
als wissenschaftler sagen dass dieses
unwetter konkret ein zeichen für den
klimawandel ist nein dieses unwetter ist
auf jeden fall erstmal ein
wetterphänomen aber das unwetter wie
diese also extremwetterereignisse wie
dürren wie hagelschlag wie auch
starkregen ereignisse immer häufiger
auftreten hängt eben sehr wohl mit dem
klimawandel zusammen herr lauterbach hat
vorhin schon kurz erwähnt wenn die
atmosphäre immer wärmer wird dann kann
sie mehr feuchtigkeit aufnehmen das ist
energie die muss sich entladen und das
tut sie eben sehr gerne in kräftigen
niederschlägen dann den jet habe ich
eben schon erwähnt der dazu sorgt dass
unsere wetter systeme hier in
mitteleuropa so ein bisschen vom kurs
abkommen und häufiger mal an ort und
stelle verharren und das können wir uns
in der metrologie immer merken zu viel
vom selben ist immer schlecht ob das nur
dürre ist oder starkregen katja ganz
herzlichen dank für diesen schnellen
informationskanal danke nach mainz und
überhaupt für all ihre arbeit und damit
sind wir wieder zurück in der runde und
fragen uns frau kemfert was kann die
politik jetzt eigentlich noch aufholen
und in welcher geschwindigkeit musik ist
aufholen sie muss sehr schnell werden
was vor allen dingen den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien angeht was die
verkehrswende angeht weg von fossilen
energien hin eben auch zu einer stärkung
des schienenverkehrs des bahnverkehrs
des rpnv all diese dinge brauchen zeit
aber wir müssen jetzt einfach den turbo
einigen europa hat uns selbst auch den
rahmen dafür gegeben dass wir schnell
werden sollen die gelder sind da die
wirtschaftshilfen auch aber es haperte
eben in der vergangenheit sehr stark
daran dass der politische wille fehlte
technisch ist das alles möglich und wir
können auch wirklich den turbo jetzt
starten wir müssen an zwei fronten
agiert und das eine ist die emissionen
senken ausbau erneuerbarer energien das
andere ist aber auch die anpassung wir
müssen uns auch vorbereiten gerade sagen
genommen so sich ja auch jetzt erst mal
vor solchen katastrophen geschützt sein
er soll nach wenn sie noch 80 jahre
passieren ja in der fachwelt nennen wir
dass die anpassung an den klimawandel
das fängt an eben von flutwänden und
endet eben auch bei entsprechender in
berlin sitzen wir hier gerade jetzt da
die auch in städten auftritt durch
grünflächen durch entsprechende
wasserknappheit in die wir auch schon
erleben und sich darauf vorbereiten die
architektur genauso der städte bauch all
das ist ja bekannt aber es passiert zu
wenig und es wird vor allen dingen nicht
durchdekliniert in den politischen
ebenen dass das alle stattfinden und
alles kostet natürlich wahnsinnig viel
geld also jede anpassung an diesen
klimawandel kostet geld der klimaschutz
selber kostet aufhellen aber er kann
dann irgendwann geld sparen das war ihre
these von eben wir gucken noch mal karl
lauterbach nach amerika da gibt es eben
an der westküste 46 47 48 grad celsius
eine hitzewelle ungekannten ausmaßes was
denken sie wird das politisch noch
zusätzlich bewirken
na ja es würde in den vereinigten
staaten mitte dazu führen dass also
bradl teil der bevölkerung sich mehr mit
dem thema beschäftigen
aber man muss ganz ehrlich sagen also
wenn wir die wende nicht hinbekommen und
ich bin in der tendenz ehrlich gesagt
leute ich jetzt gleich in eine minute
nochmal aber ich bin pessimistischer
wenn wir die wende nicht hinbekommen
dann werden große teile kaliforniens
nicht mehr bewohnbar sein
das ist einfach das risiko ist dann zu
hoch dass dort habe und gut abbrennt und
die brände sind auch sehr also ungesund
für diejenigen die nicht direkt
betroffen sind 216 feinstäube frei die
über hunderte von kilometern weg gehen
das ist einfach also ein platz so wo man
nicht der südwesten der vereinigten
staaten der wird unbewohnbar werden und
die menschen wären weg gehen
insbesondere die menschen die verstehen
was sie eben schon gesprochen haben also
was geht was wird ja nur schlechter also
selbst selbst wenn die vereinigten
staaten jetzt sage ich ja mal durch ein
wunder kein co2 mehr freisetzen würden
sondern wären klimaneutral wovon sie
lichtjahre entfernt sind auch die
ankündigung von baden sind da wenig wert
da wird es wahrscheinlich noch nichtmals
durch den kongress bekommen weil ihn
dort die eigenen demokraten stoppen
geschweige denn durch den senat aber
sagen was wäre so durch ein wunder wäre
also plötzlich die co2 neutralität in
usa erreicht dann ginge es ja noch 80
jahre weiter mit diesen riesigen bränden
mit dieser hitze mit 50 grad da will ja
keiner leben das heißt wenn ich das nach
vorne denke mich überrascht ist dass da
jetzt überhaupt noch jemand investiert
und wohnen will und ich bin in der
tendenz bin ich also da also auch jetzt
in vorbereitungen sie hatten das eben
schon erwähnt dass ich da ein buch
schreibe ich interessiere mich schon
seit ein paar jahren für dieses thema
ich bin in der tendenz sehr
pessimistisch weil die leute auch
unterschätzen wie groß die aufgabe ist
also die erneuerbaren energien sind ja
nur einen teil der aufgabe vor kämpft
hat es eben schon also dargestellt
richtig einteilt aber da habe bisher nur
ein fünftel geschafft 20 prozent der
primärenergie die wir in deutschland
derzeit verbrauchen kommen aus
erneuerbaren energien 80 prozent müssen
noch geleistet werden
das um das in 15 jahren wenn man das
schaffen will dann muss ein umbau
stattfinden der nichts mit dem zu tun
also was wir beschlossen haben politik
und damit sind sie noch einmal bei frau
hoffmann
es ist hoffmann hier auch wie wir gerade
verstanden haben und es ist interessant
zu bedenken
in den augen aller auch eine
sicherheitsfrage es ist sogar eine
militärisch hoch interessante frage weil
auch das militär
natürlich sagt zwei drittel unserer
größten und wichtigsten plätze und wie
soll man sagen eigenschaft eigenen
liegenschaften entschuldigung sind
gefährdet durch den klimawandel
es ist also auch eine frage des der
internationalen sicherheit
was denken sie wird nun tatsächlich eine
amerikanische regierung unter und mit
joe biden tun um daran an dieser
situation an dieser gefahrenlage etwas
zu verändern kann er es überhaupt oder
sagen sie herr lauterbach
das wird nicht geschehen also ich glaube
wir sind schon an einem moment einer
bewusstseinsänderung und zwar in europa
in deutschland in europa mit mit dem
green deal in deutschland glaube ich
sieht man das daran dass herr laschet
nicht mehr politisches kapital schlagen
können wird aus dieser flut wie das
schröder noch 2002 konto oder gar helmut
schmidt weil man immer den klimawandel
mitdenkt und dann auch die rolle der cdu
natürlich darin die bisher eher gebremst
hat bei den maßnahmen also für ihn wird
sich das glaube ich nicht mehr in
politisches kapital im wahlkampf oder
wandern dass man hat jetzt erstmals ein
dafür dass sich das ändert ja aber
keiner hat doch ein interesse daran dass
schienen schmelzen und das straßen
irgendwie nach geben also es ist ja
wirklich ein angriff auf die
infrastruktur eines landes
ja und das hat natürlich joe biden ganz
klar erkannt und deshalb ist es auch ein
enorm wichtiges signal dass er jetzt
gesagt hat ich kehre zum klima abkommen
von paris zurück er hat eine ganz hoch
symbolische klimakonferenz im frühjahr
gemacht das problem ist im wesentlichen
haben wir im bisher ankündigung und
keine konkreten maßnahmen wir haben
ziele die angekündigt werden und die
ziele die joe biden ankündigt obwohl es
mit viel pomp passiert sind nicht
besonders ehrgeizig er über das was er
sich für zwanzig dreißig für die usa
vornimmt ist deutlich weniger als das
was sich europa vornimmt und ich würde
wirklich sagen die usa
sind das größte problem in diesem im
klimawandel einbrecher einen amerikaner
konsumiert pro kopf dreimal so viel co2
ausstoß wie ein chinese und auch
deutlich mehr als ein deutscher und
insofern sind die usa wirklich das
hauptproblem und wir wissen nicht ob joe
biden das sozusagen das letzte aufbäumen
des guten amerika ist was wir sehen und
auf ihnen dann jemand folgt der wieder
in trumps richtung marschiert oder ob
sein versuch jetzt dem klima handel mit
dem klimawandel einhalt zu gebieten
tatsächlich fortgesetzt wird als ein
kontinuierlicher kurs wird und das
wasser lauterbach gesagt hat ist
natürlich total richtig
er hat joe biden hat ein
investitionsprogramm klima
investitionsprogramm in den kongress
gebracht das nicht angenommen worden ist
er hat probleme mit bundesstaaten
das wird vor gericht gezogen gegen seine
umweltpolitischen maßnahmen also das ist
enorm schwierig das durchzusetzen auch
gegen opposition aus den eigenen reihen
also ein wirklich ein natürlich super
wichtig symbolisch dass er sich jetzt
dafür einsetzt dass der carry benannt
hat ihn nach moskau schicken
aber ob dann das tatsächlich umsetzt in
konkrete maßnahme da ist noch ein großes
fragezeichen und in ein trennen von der
fossilen energiegewinnung eckart von
hirschhausen die frage noch mal nach dem
zeitpunkt teilen sie den pessimismus von
karl lauterbach wissenschaft ich hatte
leider sehr recht
wir haben uns auch diesen fragen schon
oft ausgetauscht aber das müssen wir
selbst uns nicht weiter wenn wir uns
einmal klar machen ich bin total
schlecht befreundet haben für mein buch
mensch erde wir könnten es so schön
haben auch zitiert mit diesem
großartigen satz naturgesetze sind nicht
verhandelbar
also das was christiane hoffmann gerade
beschrieben hat dass wir immer glauben
irgendein co2 moleküle ist schon
beeindruckt wenn wir 2015 paris
unterschreiben oder wenn
die usa jetzt wieder oder auch frau von
der leyen etwas verkündet da ist noch
kein co2 moleküle wieder zurückgekehrt
und mit karl lauterbach und unserer von
allein sind ja auch drei ärzte mit
diesem thema beschäftigt und deswegen
möchte ich nicht mehr über infrastruktur
reden soll ich möchte auch darüber reden
was macht das mit uns menschen
wer glaubt dass wirtschaft wichtiger ist
als gesundheit kann ja mal versuchen
sein geld zu zählen während der die luft
anhält
diese priorisierung von wirtschaft die
geht mir der hat sich auf den st ich
möchte es mal so deutlich sagen warum
weil wir immer noch einer
wachstumsideologie anhängen die krank
ist und die in den usa auch sozusagen
mit wir haben jetzt 1000 milliarden
irgendwie europaweit um wieder
wirtschaft anzuschieben
dieses geld ist nicht automatisch
gekoppelt und das war eine große
forderung auch von weltweiten
gesundheits verbänden harry kaffee zu
sagen wenn wir so viel geld investieren
jetzt lass uns das doch bitte mit der
priorität tun wirklich diese
nachhaltigkeit an erster stelle zu
stellen
es gibt dinge die sind ihre version ich
glaube dass das auch ein denkfehler ist
wenn man ein ei in ein heißes wasserbad
tut mit 42 grad dann ist es irgendwann
hart wenn das wasser abkühlt wird nicht
mehr weiß woraus bestehen wir bestehen
auch wie ein ei aus was er heute aus
proteinen unser hirn ist bei 42 grad im
arsch ich werde jetzt sehr deutlich es
ist irreversibel gestört warum geht
jedes feld bei thermometer auf der welt
nur bis 41 grad weil wir mehr nicht
aushalten das heißt ist eine absolute
illusion dass wir menschen uns an dinge
gewöhnen werden damit haben wir uns
lange sozusagen herausgeredet wir
dachten wir sind so reich wir werden uns
da irgendwie raus kaufen kein mensch
kann sich seine eigene außentemperatur
kaufen noch nicht mal ein privat
versichert und noch nicht millionär und
deswegen müssen wir dieses thema global
verstehen wir müssen verstehen dass
gesundheitsförderung mitbewohner mit
klimawandel artensterben new global
gelöst werden und da fehlten in
deutschland eine verdammt hohe
verantwortung haben weil wir mit anderen
industrienationen die ersten waren
diesen dreck dann nach oben gepostet
haben deswegen müssen wir auch die
ersten sein damit aufhören